joining us now here on the Rich Eisen
show the day after Kobe's passing again
I still can't believe I'm saying those
words and day after delivering that
moving preamble prior to the Knicks and
nets a day after calling
LeBron's passing Kobe to become the
third all-time leading scorer in the NBA
is a longtime voice of the NBA and the
NBA Finals on ESPN and ABC Mike Breen
how are you today Mike you know you wake
up and you hope that you just had a
nightmare and and it's and it's true
it's still it's still the next day it's
still very hard to believe that that
he's gone I had the same feeling today
just washed over me that I can't believe
that that happened yesterday and III I
guess let's let's start with you know
what it was like in that building with
the players and everybody else in
Madison Square Garden it was a very
moving tribute by the Knicks and and
Dolan to go in and lend and lend the
world's most famous arena to that moment
Mike what was it like I've never
experienced anything like it I've been
doing the games for 28 years and you
know there was just this this
overwhelming sadness in the locker room
certainly and you look at coaches you
talk to players the fans it just was the
whole place just had this feeling of
shock and you know I give due credit to
the players and the coaches for going
out and playing that game and they did
the best they can but it it never felt
like the game mattered to anybody
certainly not the players and and you
know for us broadcasting the game as I
referenced it's like you just didn't
want it you didn't want to be there he
didn't want to be doing the game and I
know a lot of the players felt the same
way so yeah it just was it was just
difficult because of who he was I mean
listen as I said on the air you know we
all deal with loved ones who pass away
we all do with family and friends and
their debts and those debts are just as
tragic and they're just as sad but for
basketball fans
what he represented to the sport that
that we all loved that I've loved as a
kid that you've loved since you were a
kid very few others have represented the
sport the way he did and because of his
personality and his charisma and his
Flair and his joy of the game I mean
that's the thing that always stuck out
to me if there wasn't an NBA he'd be
playing in the park seven days a week
because he loved the game so much and I
think because of that because of who he
is
it really was somebody who touched so
many fans Mike Breen here on the Rich
Eisen show and it's you know we're from
the same area Mike we're both from the
New York City area and of the same age
and you know with you mentioned Thurman
Munson again and what you just said
before tipoff on on Sunday it resonated
with me because when he died in a plane
crash it left me with that feeling to
that the world had been turned upside
down it was much younger than but just
that that somebody that you saw and
admired and was so full of life and so
full of vigor that that person would be
taken away it's just so mind-numbing
and III give you the floor on who Kobe
was and how you learned more about him
as you've got to call more and more of
his playoff games and eventually two of
his Finals championships Mike well he
was he was one of those players that
that you thought was indestructible
and that's what makes the news yesterday
so difficult and in the fact of course
there's three young children who had
their their lives ahead of them that's
what just completely breaks your heart
but from from a from a Kobi standpoint
he just he was indestructible that no
matter what would happen he'd figure it
out he'd figure out how to wind it
figure out how to get better there was
always a way to get around whatever
adversity that he that he dealt with on
the basketball court but again the two
things that stick out to me was as I
mentioned that love of the game I mean
he it just was a pure unrequited love
that he had and the second is that even
with all the talent and he had so much
god-given talent and with all the
success that he had both individually
and team wise the thing that made him
special to me was there was not a player
in the NBA who worked harder not a
single one some maybe came close to
working as hard but nobody worked harder
I remember after he won the finals in oh
nine and that was the Finals that made
some meant so much to him because it was
the first one where it was just his team
he took his family to to Disney for for
a little vacation like right after the
finals and the kids were very small then
I think I think he just had the two
girls at the time and I was told that
you know the park didn't open until 8
o'clock but he would get up on this
vacation at 6 o'clock and this is like a
couple of weeks after the finals and go
work out at the Orlando Magic's facility
get his work out and work on the things
that he had and be back in time to get
the kids to the to the park by the time
it opened I mean that's it's the kind of
work ethic that that I think everybody
whether you're a Laker fan a Kobe fan or
not you respect it so much because the
reason he was so great the reason he
achieved all that he achieved was
because he simply worked harder than
everybody else like Breen here on the
Rich Eisen show and another part of his
legacy I mean you could make the case we
all know obviously magic and Larry and
and Jordan made the game bigger and it
made it huger and began to grow at
internationally
with the Dream Team but when it fully
bloomed as an international sport you
could say Kobe was center stage he was
right there for all of that and you told
a great story during yesterday's game
about his influence and his legacy on
the international stage when you were in
a cab I guess and I'd love for you to
tell that story here - it was in 2008
the Olympics in Beijing and I was in the
cab and the cab driver didn't speak very
hardly spoke any English but he saw that
I had a an NBC and an NBA jumper or
pullover or whatever head on and he he
turned and he pointed to it and he said
NBA Kobe Bryant Kobe Bryant and I nodded
to him and smiled and said yep Kobe
Bryant the NBA and he asked me he goes
do you know Kobe Bryant and when I told
him that I did that I had just spoken to
him the day before or or whatever he
broke down and sobbed now this is not a
little kid this is a 35 year old man
about who was crying because he met
somebody who met Kobe Bryant not that he
even had Kobe Bryant that somebody who
had been in contact with Kobe Bryant was
enough to get him like just over the
moon in terms of emotions he was he was
crying in the cab and and that that
really struck me on two things number
one and how the game had just just
completely exploded globally and his
reach and his been able to connect with
so many fans around the world so what do
you have for me basketball wise two
moments where you're at the mic and Kobe
nails the shot puts the team on his
shoulders does the Kobe thing what do
you got for me on that front exactly
remember all those Olympics in the gold
medal game they're playing Spain and
remember it's coming off an Olympics
that didn't gripe Cote go so well in o4
in in Athens and Spain is playing a
great game and it's like a two-point
game when I don't know seven minutes to
go six minutes to go and he just hit so
many big shots down the stretch in so
many passes
set up the lane wait a couple of times
it was there was a typical performance
in here you know you have a roster full
of all Allstars
and he just said it's my turn and took
over and winning the gold medal and
representing the United States meant so
much to him and that was the Olympics
that it really came back with the
players now started to realize this is
this is an honor and a responsibility to
to play for your country in the Olympics
and he took that responsibility won the
game down the stretch I mean there's so
many games like that but that's one that
really sticks out to me well I mean the
whole it's my turn that that was part of
his brand Mike I mean and it rubbed some
people the wrong way when he first
started starting a in Madison Square
Garden in the all-star game he's waving
Karl Malone's off a car Malone off the
blocks
you know it's my turn saying last night
that he remembers and when he first saw
a Kobe and Kobe had such respect for
Walt Frazier that he said he was boy was
he a cocky kid holy mackerel
and he was and then that cockiness
turned into this just this confident
presence when he walked out on the floor
you know very few athletes have had that
when they walk out on the floor and the
opponent looks at them and you're saying
how am I gonna beat this guy and I think
that's that his presence and his
confidence is what intimidated a lot of
players even both before the ball was
thrown up well before I let you go here
Mike and I appreciate you taking the
time Mike Breen here on the Rich Eisen
show what about you personally you ever
have a moment quiet moment with him
before after a game walking down a
tunnel walking in is in an arena any
anything that can that can I guess bring
this perhaps into a finer point this
conversation well we we did a QA and at
the Los Vegas summer league two years
ago so we had a chance before and it was
a little backstage area before we came
out and did the QA for the for the
people and he we started talking about
our daughters
and my daughter she works for the NBA
and we have a great connection because
of basketball and that's what he talked
about with his daughter and that's
that's the thing I keep thinking of us
how much his connection would with
basketball with his daughter and my
daughter and it was just a neat moment
and this one of the real sad things is I
don't think I've since he retired and I
was wondering about him rich because you
know basketball meant so much with to
him how would his post retirement go and
his post retirement was fantastic for
him from a standpoint of I don't think
I've ever seen him happier or never more
at peace and one of the reasons was
because the way he connected with his
family and his and his children and his
daughter and basketball that was it was
just it was wonderful to see so that's
that's the the memory that I'll take
yeah and you know III had a chance and
we started the show with this
conversation in in 2018 and the rumor
was that in around Los Angeles a lot of
hopeful Laker fans that he would just
suit out one more time one more time
whether it was an 8 or 24 just a team up
with LeBron what a what a what a dream
that would be for fans and everybody
just was assuming that would be a normal
thing for Kobe to entertain because why
wouldn't he want to do it I mean why
wouldn't he want to try one more time
and he bristled he he was he said that
that was basically an insult to him and
he was going to take it upon himself to
show every athlete that had trouble
transitioning from being an athlete into
doing something else he was going to
show everybody that it's fine for an
athlete to leave behind the playing
career and try something else that it is
possible to do something that you aren't
defined by just being an athlete and it
blew me away
I mean it blew and I got the Mamba
mentality right there and then right
right there Mike and it was obvious he
may he may have been busier after he
retired than he was when he was playing
basketball because yet he had so much
going on yeah it's it's it's funnier
it's you know the way we feel about our
sports stars
it's you know it kind of like we the way
you feel about your favorite singers or
your favorite bands is you know sports
and music they that they have this
ability to move us that you don't even
understand they the the sports the teams
we root for the players we root for the
music we listen to it gets in our hearts
gets in our soul and and it becomes so
important part of your life and it
sometimes it sounds trivial but that's
the way it is it just finds a way to to
become such an important part of your
life and why some athletes become more
of that than others I don't know it's
hard to explain but but he was one for
so many people for so many fans in my
years doing the NBA he was as important
a figure to the NBA fans and than any
player I mean obviously Michael before
and LeBron after but but he's right
there Mike thanks for the time again I
know you're a busy man and you also have
a lot going on between your temples as
you uh you broadcast yesterday is not
easy to humanize a situation like that
and include yourself in the process and
include everybody in the process by
doing that you are terrific at what you
do you know I feel that way and I just
want to say that because is we saw
yesterday life's too short man so you
got to say those things to people so
long thanks again guys so appreciate you
rich thank you
right back at you that's Mike Breen
right here on the Rich Eisen show the
day after the passing of Kobe Bryant